[Music]
so in respect your elders new respect
grandpas and grandmas submitted by who
ajumma ajumma
aren't you - that one lunch - pancake
syrup I love that [ __ ] that fake ass Hey
Ju MA oh they put - MS OH punk [ __ ]
[ __ ] a literal ass that's why I
didn't get it yeah that's [ __ ] anyway
a Chinese boy that makes me feel racist
saying that means violently pulls his
grandfather's hair Oh
after she refuses to buy him a toy what
a little [ __ ] metal [ __ ] that's not
heard of in China
I know usually you would lose your arm
it's for police officers to convince the
little boy to let go wow the police over
in just smack the kid up it's a
different age now cuz usually are
changing another parent would see that
and just step in and just smack that
foot in the face my child is pulling on
the hair of my mother I would have to
kick that kids ass into an oblivion my
kid grab [ __ ] her I don't care about
my mom her mom's hair like that I would
kick his body so hard his body flies off
in his head and his legs are still here
I do see like a flying had a football
field and going but the head and the
legs are still right here there's just a
body disconnect yes I'm gonna show you
guys a clip thank you
hey just break the kids [ __ ] hands
[Music]
Cantonese some form of Cantonese well
it's nice that the cops are not being
abusive I like I like that and it's nice
that the grandmas not being abusive but
you know the thing is now the kids being
abusive funny because like it's like
it's like usually it's the in the
stereotype is the Asian parents like
being abusive or the grandparent or or
even the cops or whatever right yeah but
the tables have turned
look what's gonna happen cuz you don't
even have to hit the kid you just have
to grab his [ __ ] wrist so [ __ ]
yeah just let's go the tendons hurt in
his arm yeah you know you mean well grab
that neck so hard I stopped breathing
and his hands gone man
I feel like if you yell at them Stern
and you know they you just scare them
that you'd be honest I've seen a kid
like literally grab at his little sister
like as I said like a church just like
grabbing at her hair and the mom just
comes over and just grab the kids
[ __ ] here and it starts to rip that
[ __ ] off yep it's amazing dude that [ __ ]
works hell yeah my mom used to rip my
hair fall yeah but none of the cops were
doing any violence back to the kid
they're just kind of like slowly trying
to pull what they like so happy
the cops are talking to the boy saying
come on where's the Chinese [ __ ] yeah
cuz then the boy was yelling I want to
buy a toy and then the grandma was
yelling I am your grandmother how can
you do this wow it's a different world
now yeah cuz all you really have to do
is grab the [ __ ] kids herring to rip
a [ __ ] patch out of his [ __ ] head
rip the patch I mean yeah it's a
different time the police thought that
the police don't want to do nothing
I mean tickling would be like the
nonviolent I don't know if tickling
could help I think with that much rage
and that boy you gotta take that [ __ ]
nightstick and put across his throat and
then squeeze them against the wall
sometimes at my parents store just
because like these kids was like super
act up and I think like the last person
you want to piss off is like an older
black lady like they'll just be right
over the head and the kid goes it's not
some sense no words no sound no crying
just magically oh you know what you're
supposed to do all of a sudden that was
the warning hit yeah yeah I mean that
was no warning yeah they come after ten
times worse then tap I raised the tablet
is enough [ __ ] with [ __ ]
yeah just put her back you start
applying for college applications
[ __ ] start stand in a straight line
that [ __ ] don't work off the soldier I
remember my mom used to preheat her
[ __ ] hand oh [ __ ] when every time she
did this all I all know it's [ __ ]
coming but I was so frozen I couldn't
move and [ __ ] like it's [ __ ] coming
she wouldn't really do that yeah she was
[ __ ] warm her hand up Oh cuz it like
gets a wet - and then her what the
purpose was more fearsome being ah-choo
in public she would always like pinch us
on our arms right here yeah my mom
[ __ ] bleed my mom they would believe
dude and then be a [ __ ] fat bruise a
little blood comes out oh I would rather
get the punch though what because that
[ __ ] hurt all about if you were in
America right and you can't [ __ ] hurt
the kids or whatever like what what
would you do like as a parent or as a
cop or like how would you deal with this
cuz I just I just [ __ ] yell at them
grabbed a little kid and I'm like [ __ ]
out do the consequences later mmm it's a
grandma mm-hmm why would just screaming
the kids [ __ ] face until his eardrums
burst yeah more more like you know like
when a dog is already barking and
getting crazy if you scream it gets them
even more going right so what the kid
just starts pulling on grandma's hair
even harder what I mean is like like an
inch from their ear and you scream to
the point where it hurts it's like oh
yeah that doesn't it yeah actually
tickles
[Applause]
that all my cousin that's why you can't
hear [ __ ] what the [ __ ] hey tip I do
like so you ever get a massage and in
day massage your forearm and it moves
your hand like this like I've been dig
my thumb into the forearm there's
pressure points yeah let me show a
pressure point you know exactly what
you're talking about it I just want to
see it though well it did it did it look
but it makes it tighter he's gonna
squeeze a hair anymore what do you
trying to do make the kid let go of no
grandma's hair oh this hurting I know
there's a pressure point taught you I
learn and the chinese kungfu there's a
pressure a little hold my hand and
you're grabbing it if you press right
here there's a protocol in the seat
right here oh oh that actually feels
kind of it uh cause you could just grab
onto the arms go with that other girl I
was hanging on to the didn't study
kungfu good enough what he should have
done easy what's that [ __ ] diagram
[ __ ] that I'm at right here she came to
the grandma this is what you have to do
right here at the forearm I cute baby oh
[ __ ] that is the place it there's a spot
here yeah that's the pressure there's a
pressure point spot yeah why do we have
this no [ __ ] food think about I think
about who's the only guy out out think
about it I don't know I remember
why does this matter can't have to have
an actual dig two points on the dick
though
oh yeah there's one right there's like
she like [ __ ] cheat on all this [ __ ]
is that what this is is this a chi
tunnel yeah it's supposed to be like chi
portals just stands - this is such a
he's got nice - dude I know he's like
touch me seriously
haha presenting my body it was for the
gun foo I think it should be a
prerequisite from now on for the Chinese
police force to know kung fu and they
should all like fight crime with kung fu
I think it's important for all of our
cops to know jiu-jitsu dude oh yeah so
at least like a purple belt level yeah
like I think it just would make things
easier for them you can disable people
without really hurting them - yeah look
at Matt Serra you know calm down calm
down calm down
you know no I'm just gonna use guns [ __ ]
that you know I think that's why the
cops here used guns
cuz the close-quarter thing is like the
last resort you don't know what they
have in their pocket and all that like
it's it's kind of I don't want to I
don't want to touch anybody like if if
there was a guy like on PCP and [ __ ] and
then they'd have superhuman strength
like I don't want to go into a jujitsu
match with them oh yeah yeah that's one
of the biggest reasons like why cops
shoot - because there's like people that
are crazy and then they can kick police
doors they could jump down from like
four-story buildings and they're still
like alive and they have superhuman
strength so a lot of people don't think
about that a lot of people are smoking
PCP oh yeah I don't know yeah I mean I
don't know there's there's there's no
reasons but I think jujitsu is like a
lifetime skill and then joining the
department you can just do a fitness
test and then get in like it's different
from knowing a long long time of martial
arts but I did see this one video where
the Japanese police force I don't know
all there's this like really big tall
black dude in Japan but he is and then
there was some kind of like fight going
on and then they don't use guns or like
anything there right but it was the
funniest [ __ ] ever because these two
guys were fighting and then the the tall
like big black dude was towering over
these like five-foot Japanese cops and
what they all did is they're kind of
like surrounding him and then one of
them just jumped in and did a double leg
tackle and then everyone piled on top of
him like a football like like a
straight-up football tackle just to
subdue one guy yeah well cuz he was big
and then you know like those Japanese
cops were really small but then they use
judo moves though okay yeah yeah but I
was like damn okay so you can't handle a
situation without guns you know you just
need ten more people yeah that's like a
like a really insensitive joke like how
many Japanese men does it take to take
one black guy down a lot I wish I could
show you the videos I love that you just
realized you can't take you
[Music]